hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
2008 was a pretty interesting year it
was my first year of University the
iPhone was one year old dubstep was
about to explode and Breaking Bad
changes television
but what most people remember from 2008
was the financial disaster that came
with it the world would go through one
of the biggest crises it had ever
witnessed 19.2 trillion dollars of
household wealth would be lost and some
of the biggest financial institutions in
the world would fail
the crisis would Mark everyone who lived
through it without knowing it many have
had their lives determined by this
recession
from the backlash against globalization
to the erosion of trust in government
financial institutions and each other it
can all be traced back to this point in
time
since the recession less people are
having kids and it's been harder to get
by and I'm even talking before covert
the 2008 crisis was the death of the
real economy after that point there was
less productivity and more money
Printing and low interest rates which
disproportionately helped the richest
people
with the way the global economy is
looking today it's increasingly
important to look back at this point in
history to understand exactly what
happened in the parallels it has to
today
this special episode will be split into
three parts
first I'll take you through the setup of
the disaster then the crash then the
death of the real economy and I'll
finish with what you can do to help
yourself let's begin the story of one of
the biggest events in human history
you are watching cool Fusion TV
[Music]
to get the full picture we need to go
back to America in 1995.
during this year the fight was on to
help low-income earners
the US government passed laws to
decrease discrimination against poorer
home Borrowers
the banks would lower lending
requirements offering packages such as
reduced payments for a number of years
soon after in 1999 the U.S government
repealed a law that stopped commercial
Banks from taking part in Investment
Banking activities
the law that they got rid of was the
glass-steagall ACT ironically this law
was made in 1933 to stop the speculation
that fueled the Great Depression it was
a fatal mistake
from 1999 onwards Banks which had
previously managed conservatively turned
to riskier and riskier Investments as
well as speculation all in an effort to
increase their returns
Banks cared less about their customers
and more about Wall Street profits
according to Noble economics Laureate
Joseph stiglitz this move played a major
role in the financial collapse that was
to come but why worry right now things
were good it was the late 1990s and
there were seemingly no economic
problems in sight for America the
internet had taken over the minds of
everyone investment Banks were throwing
money behind anything that had a.com at
the end
the result was the launch of stupid
companies like pets.com
the banks didn't care though when the
stock went up they would sell and make
their profit this was the.com bubble and
it had arrived in full force people quit
their jobs to trade stocks and shares
went crazy for example shares of
Qualcomm Rose by
2619 percent in 1999 alone
in America there was money to be made
and life was good
but something started to happen
soon investors realized that these
internet companies had no cash flow and
couldn't actually make any money and by
March 2000 it all came crashing down
the next year the September 11th attacks
would occur followed by the Enron and
Worldcom corporate accounting scandals
after these events the public and the
markets lost trust in the economy
spending trended downwards and it was
looking like the economy was heading for
a recession
to avoid this the Central Bank of the
United States the Federal Reserve
decided to lower interest rates down to
one percent
the low interest rates would increase
spending and recover confidence in the
American economy
with a low one percent interest rate and
no systemic problems in the real economy
the recovery was rapid and economic
growth was ample eventually speculation
started to migrate from stocks into real
estate
[Music]
by 2003 everyone with a good credit
score and a good job already owned a
home if you were in the business of
giving out Home Loans this was a bad
sign
to save their profit margins mortgage
lenders relaxed credit scores to get
more people in the door and increase
profits these were called subprime loans
as the money flowed in and time went on
the lending standards got lower and
lower and lower
soon there were mortgage deals that
required no income no job and no assets
so stop checking whether the income was
even real they turned to low and no doc
loans so-called Liars loans no income no
job no assets and they were still
willing to lend but help me out here how
does that make sense for the lender it
would seem to be reckless in the extreme
it was but the key assumption was that
home prices would keep going up forever
and in fact home prices Nationwide had
never declined since the Great
Depression people like acupuncturist
Rula geosmos became real estate
speculators how many properties did you
buy in this last five year period I
believe in the last five year period I
bought about six properties and what did
you buy them for for Investments
if a subprime customer defaulted it was
no problem just sell the house because
it was going to go up in value so you're
going to still make a profit
[Music]
so this next part is a bit in the weeds
but I need you to bear with me because
it's crucial to the story
so Wall Street was looking at this
situation and they saw an opportunity
you see there were two groups of people
that could be linked here on the one
side were the mortgage lenders who were
profiting from a newly found Market they
wanted to get rid of these risky loans
because they knew that these loans were
junk and had a huge liability
on the other hand you had institutional
investors who were looking for ways to
increase their returns since interest
rates were low at one percent high yield
products were off the table
the Wall Street Banks had an idea and
they got to work offering the perfect
high yielding product the
mortgage-backed security
these were a bundle of individual
mortgage debts sold as shares these
shares would give back the investors
that bought them a safe fixed income
some rather devious Bankers realized
that they could use an old Financial
tool in combination with mortgage-backed
Securities to make unimaginable amounts
of money if they use this tool in the
housing market they could make tens of
billions of dollars in just months this
tool was the CDO collateralized debt
obligation to give you an idea of how
lovely these products were the bank that
invented them went bankrupt due to a
massive insider trading scandal one way
to imagine a CDO product is to think of
it as a box this box gets filled with
monthly repayments from a group of
mortgages and other debt such as car
loans and student loans the Box can
generate income to investors who buy it
it's divided into different levels each
level represents a different risk a CDO
works like three cascading trays
as money comes in the top tray fills
first then spills over into the middle
and whatever is left into the bottom the
money comes from homeowners paying off
their mortgages
if some owners don't pay and default on
their mortgage less money comes in and
the bottom tray may not get filled this
makes the bottom tray riskier and the
top tray safer to compensate for the
higher risk the bottom tray receives a
higher rate of return while the top
receives a lower but still nice return
the aim of this was to diversify the
risk but there was a fatal flaw since
the Box had safe Prime Home Loans mixed
in with loans to people who had no job
the whole thing was risky all of the
risk was passed to investors who
purchased these debt boxes meanwhile the
lenders and the banks profited
handsomely by charging High fees this
system was a ticking time bomb
lenders didn't care anymore about
whether a borrower could repay so they
started making riskier loans
the investment Banks didn't care either
the more cdos they sold the higher their
profits
as the financial assets became more
complex and harder to Value the majority
didn't understand how these instruments
worked they turned to credit rating
agencies for clarity The Hope was that
these institutions would do their
homework for them and determine risk
correctly but as it goes the rating
agencies completely screwed up they
rated these debt boxes as AAA the
highest possible rating
this signaled that they were extremely
safe good enough for Pension funds and
The Wider economy to invest in
but there's a question remaining why did
the writing agencies rate these debt
boxes as high quality
well sadly it was because the rating
agencies made billions of dollars in
doing so if a bank came to them asking
to rate their box filled with junk a
rating agency would know that if they
gave the product the true junk rating
the banks would just go to another
rating agency down the road to get the
AAA rating they desired
rating all of these boxes AAA meant that
the money kept flowing into the rating
agencies this was another key component
to the disaster
these false ratings would later spread
America's problems to the rest of the
world
between 2000 and 2007 The subprime
Mortgage Debt included in the packages
increased from 5 to 36 percent
they saw a remarkable success growing
from an estimated 20 billion in 2004 to
over 180 billion in 2007. Bankers were
personally making millions to tens of
millions in bonuses
while this was going on there were some
mad scientists in the financial industry
that were creating Financial weapons of
mass destruction
this is where things go insane and the
greed was in full swing
the final stage of the greed was the
invention of the mortgage credit default
swap
this was a financial instrument that
worked as insurance against failed
Mortgage Debt products
so it's an insurance contract it is an
insurance contract but they've been very
careful not to call it that
because if it were Insurance it would be
regulated this is actually the security
this is the selling document for the
Securities I think anybody ever read
this stuff I doubt very many people read
it these complex financial instruments
were actually designed by mathematicians
and physicists who used algorithms and
computer models to reconstitute the
unreliable loans in ways that were
supposed to eliminate most of the risk
obviously they turned out to be wrong
why because you can't model human
behavior with math they are complex in
effect mortgage science projects devised
by these Nobel track physicists who came
to work on Wall Street and it didn't
stop Wall Street from making billions
selling them to Banks Pension funds and
other institutional investors all over
the world how big is the market for
credit default swaps we really don't
know there's this voluntary survey that
claims that the market is in the range
of 50 to 60 or so trillion dollars
sort of alarming that in a market that
big we don't even know how big it is to
within say 10 trillion dollars
this enabled Banks to bet on the
direction of a mortgage price if they
guessed right they'll make a bunch of
money
think of it for a moment as a football
game people in the stands may also have
a financial stake in the outcome in the
form of a bet with a friend or a bookie
the new bet that arose over the last
several years is a bet based on whether
people will default on their mortgages
and that was the bet that blew up Wall
Street
and craziest still Banks could bet on
the outcome of the previous bet and
Banks could bet on the bed of that bet
because these are swaps and technically
not Insurance the banks didn't need any
cash to back up their bets if they go
bad what could possibly go wrong and it
used to be illegal it was very illegal
100 years ago because it had brought
down the market in 1907 and they said
we're not going to let this happen again
and then a hundred years later in 2000
we rolled them all back in retrospect
giving Wall Street immunity from State
gambling laws and legalizing activity
that had been banned for most of the
20th century should have given lawmakers
pause
if it sounds meaningless it basically is
these products created no value in the
economy but we're making Banks a whole
bunch of money
insurance companies such as AIG saw
their profits soar
Financial engineering was running
rampant and there was no one supervising
any of these products
in October 2004 the Securities and
Exchange Commission or SEC bizarrely
relaxed the liquidity requirements of
five banks Goldman Sachs Merrill Lynch
Lehman Brothers bear Stearns and Morgan
Stanley this slit the fire
the more the banks borrowed the higher
their Leverage
the SEC somehow decided to let
investment Banks gamble a lot more
that was nuts I don't know why they did
that
from 2004 to 2007 these investment Banks
each significantly increased their
financial leverage this Amplified gains
but also Amplified losses
as they gambled more these Banks became
extremely vulnerable to financial shocks
in 2007 they reported 4.1 trillion
dollars in debt that was about 30
percent of U.S GDP at the time the stage
was now fully set for a moment that
would shake the world
during 2004 as the U.S economy picked up
pace the U.S Central Bank started to
increase interest rates this would set
off a chain reaction event because
financial institutions had offered up
many adjustable rate loans based on low
rates
home buyers would enjoy these low rates
for about two to three years after this
period the rates would reset to align
with the market interest rate
but when you combine Rising rates with
low income subprime customers it was a
disaster home buyers went from paying
little to no monthly interest payments
to their payments suddenly snapping up
to multiple times higher to meet the
market
many just couldn't pay up but after two
three or five years those rates reset
they went up and so did the monthly
payment so a mortgage of say eight
hundred dollars a month could easily
jump to fifteen hundred dollars
by mid-2006 an increasing number of
defaults caused home prices to fall
homes were now worth less than their
mortgage loans many homeowners stopped
paying their mortgages and went into
foreclosure
this is where the crisis starts gaining
momentum as more foreclosures occurred
home prices fell further while demand
kept decreasing as well
as 2007 got underway nearly 1.3 million
properties were foreclosed
there was a rumbling that something big
was going on when the subprime
specialist lender near Century Financial
filed for bankruptcy then one subprime
lender after another files for
bankruptcy
by the end of 2007 2.3 million homes had
been foreclosed and the subprime
mortgage crisis was officially underway
the high default rates by the homeowners
led to a rapid devaluation of the
financially engineered products from
before
investors were now aware of the risks
and they were now trying to sell these
toxic debt boxes at all costs
in March of 2007 Federal Reserve
chairman Ben Bernanke tries to calm the
market he States the subprime loan issue
is contained he couldn't have been more
wrong
ironically in October 2022 Ben Bernanke
would win the Nobel Prize for economics
you're about to see why this is so
ironic
in August of 2007 a bombshell
announcement rattles the market
Francis B and P Paribas announces that
there is no liquidity in the global
market for mortgage-backed securities
in other words nobody wants to buy the
debt boxes anymore they're essentially
worthless other European Banks follow
with similar announcements
the real picture was becoming clear the
mortgage-backed Securities that were
supposed to be Triple A and safe are in
reality worthless and even worse they
had spread through the Global Financial
system undetected like a cancer
as a result of these shock announcements
there was a panic among Financial firms
and Banks investors looked around and
wanted to pull any funding that was
thought to be vulnerable to mortgage
losses financial institutions struggled
to assess the values of their books what
they thought was worth trillions of
dollars could actually be worth close to
zero
the contagion continued to spread
September 2007
UK Bank Northern Rock was also playing
with high leverage and financially
engineered products and they have to be
bailed out by the bank of England
investors then queued to take their
money out
it was the first bank run in the UK
since 1866.
while all of this was going on the
Federal Reserve was still clueless they
forecasted that the Slowdown would be
mild stating that there would still be
three percent GDP growth come on guys
March of 2008 sees bear Stones Fall bear
Stearns was a pillar of Wall Street
dating back to 1923 and was the fifth
largest Investment Bank
The Firm carried a notional market value
of 13.4 trillion dollars
so how did this number get so high
this was because they were also being
Reckless and using very high leverage
which multiplied their losses bear
Stearns bet big on the mortgage markets
and lost
the markets have certainly gotten worse
but our liquidity position has not
changed at all our balance sheet has not
weakened at all and yet 48 hours later
everything changes this morning Schwartz
said that the firm's cash position had
deteriorated sharply over the past day
questions now being asked at this loss
of three and a half billion dollars in
market value today alone they were
bought by JP Morgan for two dollars a
share just earlier in the year Beth
Stearns was worth a hundred and seventy
dollars per share
Global Panic ensued and it was at a
fever pitch
Lehman Brothers the fourth largest
Investment Bank is being looked at as
the next to fall it was also heavily
exposed to the subprime mortgage
Financial products
Layman CFO Erin Cullen calmed investors
by boasting of a profit of 489 million
the stock jumps 48 on the news but all
wasn't as it seems a later 2010 report
by the court examiner stated that Lehman
Executives regularly used accounting
gimmicks at the end of each quarter to
make their financials seem less shaky
than they really were
in reality their risky commercial real
estate holdings were 30 times greater
than their capital
Lehman Brothers were so highly leveraged
that a three to five percent decline in
real estate values would completely wipe
out all of their capital
by June Lehman Brothers reported A 2.6
billion loss which no amount of
accounting magic could hide their stock
Falls by 73 percent
meanwhile other Banks such as Morgan
Stanley and Goldman Sachs started
betting against the mortgage Securities
which they were still selling and they
would make hundreds of millions of
dollars while investors lost everything
unbelievable at this time the US had now
tipped into recession as GDP fell by 2.1
percent
September 2008 the crisis begins to spin
out of control and Lehman Brothers
collapses this marks the largest U.S
bankruptcy of all time the US government
said it won't bail out Lehman which last
week announced more than 3.9 billion
dollars in losses shares in Lehman
Brothers have plummeted more than 80
percent in 2008 alone
everybody in the west at least owns a
lot of people have got pensions and
these pensions invest in stock markets
and a lot of the shares are actually the
shares of Banks and when the back when
Bank shares get hammered people's
pensions get hammered so everybody loses
Lehman Brothers is going bankrupt
after talks to pull them back from the
abyss collapsed in financial markets
from Asia to Europe are doing their
utmost to prevent Monday from turning
from dark to Black
[Music]
this is going to be one of the Watershed
days in financial markets history it was
a manic Monday in the financial markets
the Dow tumbled more than 500 points
after two pillars of the street tumbled
over the weekend Lehman Brothers a 158
year old firm filed for bankruptcy I
don't think anyone really expected A
bank's biggest reason to uh you know be
in a position that it's in now brought
down by bad mortgage Investments Lehman
which has 25
000 employees will be liquidated I'm
starting to find another job meanwhile
Merrill Lynch fearing it could be next
agreed in an act of desperation to a
shotgun marriage with Bank of America so
in just six months three of the five
biggest independent firms on Wall Street
have now disappeared bear Stearns which
collapsed last spring Lehman Brothers
and Merrill Lynch treasury secretary
Henry
the banks were all scared and they
stopped lending to each other and the
financial system froze
companies couldn't order parts pay for
staff and businesses ground to a halt
and if nothing was done planes would
have to stop Flying
we came as close as we have ever come in
history to a total Cardiac Arrest not
just of the American economy but the
entire world economy meaning everybody
is afraid to lend to everybody else
credit simply freezes and an economy a
modern economy can't function that way a
modern economy can't function without
credit for more than even a couple of
hours frankly seconds GE the pillar of
American manufacturing was having a hard
time getting short-term credits so was
Harvard University wage bills were not
being paid
knowing that something had to be done
the infamous bailout started
on September 16 2008 the U.S federal
reserve stepped in to buy AIG the
largest insurer in the U.S
while Lehman was just another bank AIG
presented a systemic risk to the entire
Financial system or so they told us it
was an 85 billion loan and this was the
origin of the famous too big to fail
argument we're in an urgent situation
and the consequences will grow worse
each day
if we do not act
the U.S government gave the banks 700
billion dollars to purchase toxic assets
and Bank shares to stop them from
falling any lower
it did work but the biggest banks just
ended up being even larger after buying
up all the other failing Banks
the use of hundreds of billions of
dollars of taxpayers money to bail out
these Banks sparked complete outrage it
was the beginning of mass distrust in
institutions and governments the
immediate result was the Occupy Wall
Street movement and the invention of
Bitcoin
bailing out the banks was an unpopular
move
but the other option wasn't fun either
the crash of 1929 and the subsequent
Great Depression lasted for almost a
decade there's arguments to be made on
both sides
as for now the crisis was still in full
swing the Federal Reserve also cut
interest rates in the hope of restoring
the market in total during the fourth
quarter of 2008 the Central Bank of the
United States purchased 2.5 trillion
dollars of government debt and junk
private assets from the banks up until
that point this was the largest monetary
policy action in the history of the
world
by 2009 the stock market has fallen 50
from its 2007 highs Pension funds were
completely wiped out
[Music]
[Music]
as we know it wasn't just the US that
suffered institutions and governments
around the world owned American Assets
in 2008 it became obvious that the
crisis was going to have Global
repercussions
after the fall of Lehman Brothers Banks
and corporations globally began to fail
in the UK hbos was taken over by Lloyd
and the UK government steps in to save
its banking system
with lending markets drying up around
the world the central banks of the
United States European Union Australia
Canada and Japan coordinated injecting
cash into debt markets for the first
time since 9 11.
November of 2008 sees the international
monetary fund approved loans to
stabilize Ukraine and Iceland
by December 2008 riots had broken out in
Greece much of the day the clashes were
centered around the Greek Parliament one
of the few buildings here being
adequately protected Iceland was hit
particularly bad relative to the size of
its economy the systemic collapse was
the largest experienced by any country
in economic history
some of the biggest banks in the nation
became worthless
and their stock market fell by almost 80
percent
here is elsewhere the police are first
to meet the anger and despair amongst
the population
during the past weekend thousands have
taken to the streets to protest against
their government and allege corruption
amongst bank managers
for the first time in history in this
tiny Nation leading politicians and
businessmen are now protected by armed
guards
land Banky was one of three big
Icelandic banks that had engaged in an
uncontrolled learning spree abroad
when the international credit crunch hit
they had accumulated loans worth 12
times the nation's GDP
when the banks defaulted the state had
to take over their debts worth more than
60 billion dollars
unlike many countries the people of
Iceland actually chased out their
bankers and jailed them meanwhile in the
United States the top five Lehman
Executives walked away with two billion
dollars and they got to keep the money
the rest of Europe was still hit hard
the results of which was the European
debt crisis a multi-year economic crisis
that took place from 2009 until the end
of the 2010s some member states namely
Portugal Greece Spain and Ireland were
unable to repay or refinance their
government debt until today countries
like Greece are still struggling to
overcome their financial issues
on April 10 2009 Time Magazine declared
quote more quickly than it began the
banking crisis is over
but was it really problems still
persisted wages and incomes continued to
languish the real economy was limping
people would be out of work for a few
years to come and by 2010 unemployments
around the world had risen hitting
almost 10 percent in the United States
and Europe
six million Americans lost their jobs
and 8 million lost their home Oscar
Munoz used to sell real estate now his
company clears out foreclosed homes I
wonder do you ever come to houses where
the people are still here absolutely
that's really a sad situation I'd rather
not meet the people why not it's not
easy to to come in and move a family out
it's it's just our job to do it for the
bank it's it's just the nature of of
what's going on in the market right now
[Music]
[Music]
in 2010 regulatory action was finally
taken the US government passed the
Dodd-Frank Act it included more
oversight and transparency for
financially engineered products limits
on risky Bank Investments tied to
regulation for rating agencies the whole
aim was to stop this kind of disaster
from ever happening again
but unfortunately it doesn't seem to
have worked
today banks have reinvented the debt
boxes and the tools used to speculate on
them this time they're calling them
bespoke collateralized synthetic
obligations this time they're using
corporate debt instead of mortgages
2022 saw a large spike in activity
quadrupling to 40 billion dollars in
this year alone
let's just hope that corporations don't
all default on their debt due to a
systemic shock I personally don't think
we'll have another crisis exactly the
same as 2008 but safe to say these
stupid Financial experiments aren't
helping I really sincerely hope that
there's not more of them out there which
we just don't know about
so what happened next what scars did
such a disaster leave on the economy
well there's some strong arguments to be
made that there has been no real economy
since 2008.
if you look at the GDP per capita of the
real economy of the United States it
never recovered it has been below Trend
since 2008.
if you're in your late 30s onwards this
is probably why it felt harder for the
average person to get ahead since the
crash
in the United States alone it's
projected that an adult that lived
through the crash has lost about seventy
thousand dollars in lifetime earnings
younger people were less affected but
less employment opportunities still set
them back for the first time a whole
generation would be poorer than their
parents it's not uncommon for younger
people to live paycheck to paycheck
funding their lives would by now pay
later debt
subsequently the fertility rates around
the world have decreased significantly
after 2008. there may be other
explanations for the phenomenon but the
charts are clear a financial disaster
would certainly impact the way families
would plan for their future
after the 2008 crisis Central Banks
gained more power they set interest
rates low for so long that the stock
market and eventually the whole
financial system adjusted and settled
around the state
low interest rates meant cheap money
people companies and governments
borrowed money with virtually no
interest
Investments turn risky and excessive
debt distorted many markets
by the mid-2010s these conditions had
become the scaffolding for the whole
financial system growth became dependent
on central banks keeping these
conditions the same
wealth inequality exploded as those
closest to the financial industry got
extremely rich while the rest of the
general populace stayed the same
by the late 2010s many economic
commentators were referring to this as
the everything bubble
first it was stocks
then it was housing
then it's the debt market now which
controls everything
[Music]
this next point is key to really
understanding the death of the real
economy economic productivity this is
the measure of how much stuff you get
out from the resources that you put in
since 2008 it's been severely injured
due to zero interest rates for so long
after 2008 the investment that would
have gone to productive areas of the
economy catapulted into riskier sectors
the real economy just didn't get the
capital it needed to innovate and
develop and do things more efficiently
low economic productivity affects real
wage growth living standards and quality
of life
even former Federal Reserve chair Janet
Yellen called it the quote most
important factor determining continued
advancements in living standards
this is why when our leaders told us
that the economy was booming in the
2010s it really didn't feel like that to
many people productivity was gone it's a
missing piece of the 21st century
economic story that's often left out
then we come to 2020 and the pandemic
saw central banks respond much quicker
with a lot of force printing trillions
of dollars as the economy was slowing to
a halt there's no denying that this
mitigated the pain but was this an
overreaction many think so economic
Professor Jeremy Siegel called it a
Monumental mistake
regardless the stock market loved it and
vaulted to all-time highs
then investments into risky assets like
nfts shot up
eventually there was too much money in
the system and not enough goods and the
prices of everything started to rise
aside from the Fallout of covert and the
war in Ukraine a component of inflation
today comes from the actions of central
banks
in the later stage of this roller
coaster central banks have panicked at
the large inflation and have started
raising rates this was to slow down the
economy and reduce demand and this is
supposed to bring down inflation but as
stated low rates and easy money had
become the scaffolding of the financial
system raising interest rates reverses
these conditions that the financial
system was used to
this is why as soon as interest rates
start Rising everything seems to be
falling apart stock markets are crashing
and companies are laying off staff the
whole system just isn't used to a normal
interest rate environment
today there's a lot more debt in the
system than in 2008 and this was thanks
to central banks keeping interest rates
near zero for more than a decade
increasing rates would make this large
volume of debt harder to manage for
individuals and governments countries
like Australia Canada and the UK have a
lot of variable rate mortgages which
will snap higher to Market rates over
the next few years subprime car loans
and credit card loans are seeing
increased defaults meanwhile Credit
Suisse is in trouble and they're selling
part of their domestic Bank
Central Bank liquidity swaps are going
crazy in Switzerland doubling in the
past couple of weeks it looks like we're
going to have another recession but what
happens beyond that is anyone's guess
after almost 15 years the 2008 recession
has taught us several lessons it was the
loose lending standards and low Central
Bank interest rates that started the
problem Financial engineering spread it
to the world bad policy accounting fraud
and poor credit rating agencies fan the
Flames although structural reform has
taken place since 2008 we should also
take a deeper look into central banks
and their decisions they always seem to
print and leave rates too low for too
long distorting markets and blowing up
bubbles only to pop these bubbles later
it's a scenario that seems to be playing
out again today all in all the real
lesson that we as a society never seem
to learn is to keep those in charge
accountable and also to plan for the
unpredictable
so for you personally what can you do if
you're worried and don't trust our
expert leaders the key is to avoid risk
if you are inclined to keep your money
safe think about assets that have little
to no risk or financial engineering
behind them some believe physical gold
and silver as boring as they may seem
are the ultimate riskless assets others
believe government bonds are others
still think plain old cash is best talk
to a financial professional to make that
personal decision and to sleep easier at
night
so before I finally go I do want to hear
some stories from 2008 from you guys I
know I was too young to be impacted
directly but I did know and I got a
sense that the world was changing while
I was studying in University so what do
you remember from this period
anyway a massive thanks for watching
this episode did take a lot of effort to
bring to life so I do want to thank you
for sticking till the end if you did
like it take a look around the channel
there's a lot of interesting stuff on
science technology business and finance
in the next episode we'll move away from
Finance for a second and take a look at
an interesting story
did you know that apart from Steve Jobs
and Steve Wozniak Apple had a third
co-founder and he sold 10 of his Apple
shares for a measly 800 in 1976.
well I'll see you next time in that
episode my name is dagogo and you've
been watching cold fusion
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
forever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cold fusion it's new thinking